let's say that we want to evaluate this
indefinite integral right over here and
you immediately say hey you got the
square root of 4 minus x squared in the
denominator you could try u substitution
but it really doesn't simplify this in
any reasonable way how do you tackle
this and an insight that you might have
as well this thing the square root of 4
minus x squared this looks like
something that i might get if i'm
dealing with the pythagorean theorem if
i'm solving for non-hypotenuse sides of
the pythagorean theorem especially if
the hypot if the length of the
hypotenuse is 2 this would be 2 squared
and then the other side is x then 2
squared minus x squared this would be
the length of the other side well let's
just run with that then
so
if we have
a and if and if any of you didn't feel
that inside immediately it's okay
because to be honest i never actually
did not feel that insight probably the
first time that i saw things like this
so let's say you have a right triangle
so let's just visualize that insight
that we talked about
so if the hypotenuse of the right
triangle is of length two
the hypotenuse is of length two
hypotenuse is of length two
and let's say this side right over here
actually let me do this side let's say
this side
actually i'm going to go with this side
this side right over here
is of length x
this side over here is of length x it's
a little counterintuitive because
normally we associate this side over
here with y but let's just go with it
this side right over here is of length x
then what would this side right over
here be what would this other
non-hypotenuse length be
well just if you solve for it using the
pythagorean theorem you get that it is
going to be the square root of
the hypotenuse squared 2 squared which
is just 4
minus the other side squared so minus x
squared
well that's interesting that is this
expression that is that insight that
intuition that we may have had when we
saw this right over here but still how
does that help us
well this is where the trigonometry
comes in
because if we define
if this angle right over here we say
this is theta then what is sine and
cosine of theta going to be in terms of
these sides
well let's see the sine of theta
sine of theta is equal to the opposite
over the hypotenuse is equal to x over 2
or if you want to solve for x we get x
is equal to 2 sine
theta well that's interesting what about
the cosine of theta
cosine of theta is equal to the adjacent
side square root of 4 minus x squared
over the hypotenuse or if you want to
solve for this side it's going to be we
could say that the square root of 4
minus x squared is going to be equal to
the hypotenuse times the cosine of theta
so that's interesting if x is equal to
two sine theta then this other side then
this entire expression simplifies to two
cosine theta and that seems pretty
interesting now
so let's make the substitution let's say
that x is equal to
sine
theta and if x is equal to 2 sine theta
then d
x
is going to be equal to 2 cosine theta d
theta
and then if we if x is equal to 2 sine
theta then what is this thing right over
here well we just figured out this thing
is 2 cosine theta
this thing is equal to 2 actually let me
do that orange color
2 cosine theta
this is equal to 2
cosine theta
and we were able to do this drawing this
right triangle and using the the
the the right the sohcahtoa definition
of these trig functions and obviously
you could use unit circle that's kind of
an extension of these but you could also
do it if you say hey look you know if
this is 2 sine theta you could use the
pythagorean identity or trigonometric
identities and you would see that this
entire expression if you did it that way
would simplify to 2 cosine theta
but now let's just run forward and let's
see if we can evaluate it using this
substitution so this is going to be
the indefinite integral so dx so 1 times
dx that's going to be dx is 2 cosine
theta d theta so let me write that that
is
cosine
theta
d i'll write the d theta out here and
then what's the denominator square root
of 4 minus x squared well that's 2
cosine theta again
so
that is 2
cosine
theta well this seems to work out quite
nicely
if you 2 cosine theta over 2 cosine
theta that's just going to be 1 this
simplifies
this simplifies to
d theta which is if you just evaluate
this this is just going to be equal to
theta plus c
well
this is kind of nice but we're still not
done we want this we want our our
indefinite integral in terms of x
so now let's just solve for x here so if
x is 2 cosine theta or sorry if x is 2
sine theta
so x is equal to 2
sine
x is equal to
sine theta then let's see divide both
sides by 2 x over 2 is equal to sine
theta
and then if you want to solve for theta
theta is the angle that if you take the
sine of it you get x over 2 so we could
say let's give ourselves another a
little bit more real estate that theta
is equal to the inverse sine
the inverse sine of
this thing x over 2. we could write it
that way or we could write that theta is
equal to the arc sine
the arc sine
of
the arc sine of x over 2.
so this is going to be equal to
the
r theta is arc sine of x over two so
let's just do that arc sine
of x over two
plus c and we're done we've just
evaluated that indefinite integral
now some of you might have noticed
something i kind of uh brushed past it
really fast just to give you the the big
see the see the forest for the trees but
there's some interesting details that
it's i think worth digging into a little
bit over here
so the first one is you might see that
look the restriction on x here is or or
the domain here on this expression is
restricted so let's just keep track of
that to make sure that we didn't do
anything strange when we did that
substitution
so the domain here x has to be
x has to be greater than negative 2 and
less than 2. if the absolute value of x
were equal to 2 then you'd have a 0 in
the denominator if the absolute value of
x is greater than 2 then you're going to
have a negative in the denominator and
that's not defined so this right over
here is the domain
so let's say make sure that our
substitution didn't do anything weird
with that so if x has to be between
negative 2 and 2 and we're saying x is 2
sine theta that means 2 sine theta would
have to be between negative 2 and 2. so
negative 2 would have to be less than
2 sine theta 2
sine theta which would have to be
less than 2.
we could divide all the different parts
of this compound inequality by 2 and
you're going to get negative 1 is less
than sine theta
is less than sine theta which is less
than 1.
and
the way we can do that is if theta
is
less than pi over 2
at pi over 2 sine of theta would be
equal to 1 and if theta is greater than
negative pi over 2. so if we restrict it
in this way if we say theta is going to
be in this range right over here
then then where we are restricting our
domain in a reasonable way
and this works out well because this
typically is the the range for the arc
sine function so we could feel good
about that
now another question that you might have
is okay well look you know we divided by
cosine of theta here but that's okay as
long as cosine of theta does not equal
zero because you don't want a zero in
the denominator and the good thing about
this restriction on theta is as long as
theta is greater than negative pi over
two and less than pi over two cosine of
theta is going to be it's not going to
be zero and actually it's going to be
positive if if negative pi over two or
pi over two are allowed then you would
get a zero down here and we would have
to think about restricting things in
some other ways so it looks like
everything is cool we we dug a little
deeper we said okay we haven't done
anything strange to the domain or to the
kind of unrestricted it in some strange
way and so we can feel we can feel good
about we can feel good about this about
this
this this answer that we've gotten